there were many ways how Paul Beeston
influenced medical education the
activity of Morning Report gathering all
of his residence around a table usually
with coffee and tea and having them
present there the admitting diagnosis
the history and the physical examination
of each of the patients admitted to the
medical service the previous day morning
report spread from Yale to other
institutions and is still a part of
medical education of clinical practice
today his major scientific contribution
that's been described is his lifelong
study of fever on one hand he published
with Bob Peters Dorf the causes of fever
of unknown origin and on the other at a
basic science level he figured out the
cause of fever in pursuing that work
Beason was looking for the cause of
fever at the high at the level of the
hypothalamus and discovered cytokines
along with Elijah Atkins and Charles
Donatello and others working in his
group he was someone who really could
balance and show others how to balance a
devotion to patients sitting at their
bedside pursuing the diagnosis of those
patients teaching those around him in a
very humble but highly effective manner
and coupled that with investigation in
the laboratory